for three generations the russell family
have run church farm but as well as
selling milk like many farmers they've
diversified so this is dora shepard's
heart
not far from the cows the glamping
business is in its second year the money
earned here goes directly into the local
economy for the glamping side of things
we need
well first of all we need to build it so
i we have a local carpenter in the
village who i work with then i have
cleaning and like the cleaning of the
linen and but also of the huts and the
glamping as well all together it amounts
to probably like
two to three full-time jobs which i know
does not loads but it does make a
difference when the village is only 150
people it's these business ideas the
government wants to see more of with up
to 110 million pounds to boost rural
economies
the millions of pounds announced used to
come from the eu to help rural parts of
the country now it comes from the
government it insists that local
authorities will have a greater say and
more freedom in how to spend the money
the cash comes after a report found that
the rural economy is 18
less productive than the national
average the report says that if that gap
was reduced it could add 43 billion
pounds to the uk economy and a recent
survey found 66
of people don't believe the government
was doing enough to create prosperity in
rural communities
i think rural economies have always felt
uh the sort of poor relation if you like
sort of a big sort of lack of
understanding about the business
opportunities in rural areas you've
never got enough money but it's a big
step in the right direction the fact
that his ring fence funds is really
going to help
at siren sester market stall holders are
vocal about the lack of support in rural
towns lots of the shops as you can see
are struggling on the high street and
that needs to be improved on
in way the government can do is business
rates coming right down
no i do believe there's more they can do
i think a lot have taken a dive since
covid and i do think the farm shops came
into their own a little because people
weren't going into town and as a result
i think farm shops and little village
shops
did well for for a certain length of
time but sadly that's reversed
lower wages fewer job opportunities and
poor transport links have long blighted
rural areas this new fund will help but
won't solve the major problems faced in
rural england
dan white is sky news in gloucestershire